this is the human catapult a DIY project
from West Virginia by engineer Jason
Bell it's an incredible feat of
Engineering
he just made it in his garage that's
quite cool and with preparation complete
it was time to launch a human into a
lake after the first successful launch
Jason decided to raise the stakes
when he throws people off the bridge
that's just insane
insane
indeed so how does a human catapult work
so the catapult works exactly like the
seesaw but instead of having a person on
the other side you have a piston this
piston is attached to a cylinder full of
compressed air Jason uses his air
compressor to create as much pressure as
possible and then he opens a valve and
that releases the air almost
instantaneously it rushes through a tube
and into a pneumatic cylinder where it
then pushes on a piston the piston is
attached to the short arm of the
catapult that pulls it around which also
pulls the long arm around which
catapults the person into the air
I love people like Jason this guy is
doing some wonderful engineering showing
us some great physics and he's just
doing it for fun